droht eine weltweite epidemie durch
vogelgrippe am vogelgrippevirus h 79
sind mehr als 1600 menschen erkrankt
etwa 40 prozent davon sind verstorben
jetzt hat ein japanisches forschungsteam
erschreckendes über diese virusvariante
herausgefunden sie erfüllt fast alle
voraussetzungen für eine pandemie also
für eine gigantische weltweite epidemie
die ihn auch vor grenzen kann halt macht
warum die erreger mittlerweile noch viel
gefährlicher geworden sind und was getan
wird um eine vogelgrippe pandemie zu
verhindern also wie ist die lage jetzt
den klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen direkt mal vorab die
vogelgrippe ist nichts neues und
vogelgrippe ist auch nicht gleich
vogelgrippe schon seit tausenden von
jahren befallen viren wildvögel und
hausgeflügel doch mittlerweile gibt es
nach angaben von experten und
expertinnen mindestens 15 verschiedene
varianten der erkrankung
die virusvariante h7 n9 ist im jahr 2013
das erste mal in china aufgetaucht die
erkrankten hatten sich damals alle durch
den direkten kontakt mit geflügel
angesteckt eine übertragung von mensch
zu mensch ist bislang noch nicht möglich
viele der patienten und patientinnen
leiden an schweren lungenentzündung und
fieber
infizierte tiere dagegen sind nicht
unbedingt sichtbar krank mittlerweile
haben sich die virusvarianten
weiterentwickelt und zwar mit
weitreichenden folgen für uns für ihre
studie hat das forschungsteam aus tokio
virus proben von einem chinesischen
patienten der anfang 2017 an der
vogelgrippe verstorben war genauer
untersucht und dabei haben sie gleich
drei erschreckende entdeckung gemacht
zum einen fanden sie in dieser probe
unterschiedliche varianten des erregers
das fatale daran nicht alle von ihnen
sprechen auf die wirkstoffe an die die
vermehrung des virus blockieren im
klartext heißt das also dass einige der
viren bereits resistent sind gegen
gängige grippemittel im detail handelt
es sich um sogenannte
neuraminidasehemmer die wie gesagt
normalerweise zuverlässig verhindert
haben dass sich die erreger vermehrten
zudem stellten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler fest dass es sich
bei dem identifizierten erreger um einen
sogenannten hochpathogenen subtyp das h7
neuen virus handelt bei den vorherigen
epidemien war
dagegen niedrig pathogene viren im spiel
also kurze erklärung der begriff
pathogen kommt aus dem griechischen
patras verladen und gehen für erzeugen
mit dieser bezeichnung wird also grob
gesagt die gefährlichkeit des erregers
eingestuft und auch das dritte
experiment des japanischen
forschungsteams zeigt deutlich dass wir
diese instrumente erreger keinesfalls
unterschätzen dürfen wenn versuche im
labor zeigten dass das thema simon virus
tatsächlich gelingt sich erfolgreich in
menschlichen zellen der atemwege zu
vermehren das bedeutet nichts gutes denn
das ist tatsächlich die erste
voraussetzung dafür dass die so genannte
arten schranken überwunden wird ja also
glücklicherweise gelingt dies der
resistenten varianten nicht so gut wie
den nicht resistenten virus formen in
einem weiteren test klärten die
forscherinnen und forscher auch die
zweite voraussetzung für die überwindung
der arten schranke nämlich optimieren
auch zwischen säugetieren übertragbar
sind und tatsächlich die mit h 79
infizierten frettchen hatten die
gesunden frettchen in den nachbar
käfigen angesteckt und zwar via
tröpfcheninfektion also mit atem wenn
sie mit der nicht resistenten wäre
variante infiziert waren starben die
tiere in den meisten fällen das
forschungsteam schlägt jetzt alarm denn
diese studie zeigt dass es nur noch eine
frage der zeit ist bis sich eine
besonders gefährliche virusvariante
entwickelt zitat bis jetzt ist zwar noch
keine übertragung von mensch zu mensch
dokumentiert worden doch offenbar
verbreitet sich das h7 wir uns schon
heute zwischen zeuge tier passt es sich
weiter an könnten daraus bald erreger
mit pandemie potenzial hervorgehen warnt
einer der beteiligten forscher yoshikawa
opa der worst case also eine
erregervariante die sich besonders
effektiv in menschlichen zellen vermehrt
resistent gegen gängige grippemittel ist
und somit ein tödliches potenzial hat
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler fordern jetzt dass man
die entwicklung des virus ganz genau
unter beobachtung hält und das geschieht
sehr schnell bislang ist ja eine
übertragung von mensch zu mensch noch
nicht möglich doch dies ist nach ansicht
des forschungsteams vielleicht nur noch
eine frage der zeit denn bereits vor
vier jahren zeigte sich dass die erreger
sich rasend
schnell an ihrem neuen wirte anpassen
zudem sei es dringend notwendig neue
medikamente gegen die resistenten
virusvarianten zu entwickeln dafür
schlagen sie auch gleich einen konkreten
wirkstoff vor den rna polymerase hemmer
habib ära wir wenn er kein video zu
diesem thema auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht
den genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet
ihr auch aktuell auf dem stand zu diesem
thema und zu allen anderen themen
gehalten hier also hier geht es weiter
mit etwas ganz anderem sexuelle
anziehung musik macht männer attraktiver
da ist musik drin also viel spaß dabei
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran